professor David Bailey joins us from
Aston Business School where he
specializes in UK car manufacturing so
David this business has lost twenty
billion dollars over the last 15 years
also GM's European arm what does Carlos
Tavarez gonna have to do with it well I
think they think that they want to grow
in size they want to be a bit much
bigger operation to get sort of scale
economies
I think they hope to share technology
across different brands across peugeot
citroen opel/vauxhall and they will look
to cut costs as various ways they can do
that they can do that through
procurement buying stuff together
by sharing technology I think down the
line it's going to be inevitable though
that there is likely to be plant
closures and job losses despite what
Tavarez said today so I think they're
going to have to look at that longer
term to try and cut costs the question
then would be where the axe will fall
well quite so I mean he's a particularly
renowned tough manager is it is it
inevitable that the axe is going to fall
in the UK it's not inevitable but I
think the UK plants are vulnerable for a
number of reasons one from that
excellent piece just then it's under the
uncertainty created by brexit and the
fact that some key decisions over where
say the next generation Astra will be
built will be made in 2018 slap-bang in
the middle of article 15 negotiations we
don't know whether the UK currency will
be in the single market or even in the
customs union the other factor of course
is that the UK flexible labor markets
mean that it's very easy to sack workers
in the UK so if Peugeot is looking to
close plants then it can do that more
easily in the UK than in say France
where by the way the French government
has a stake in the company and we did
see that ten years ago when they shut
that Peugeot plant near Coventry not
very far from here that plant was an
efficient plant it was a profitable
plant it was just easier to sack workers
in the UK indeed though it's not
impossible to lay off workers in
continental Europe and indeed GM did
close a plant at Bochum in Germany a few
years ago they did although put that in
context there's only been one plant
closure in Germany since the Second
World War so that shows how unusual it
is now you've got French government that
owns a stake in the firm I think they
are not going to accept any plant
closures in France you've got a German
government that said that their
number-one priority is to protect plants
and research and development capacity
there so there's a real danger
I think of a kind of French German
stitch up here and the British being
left on the site going forward
I don't think all is lost the key
decision is going to be in 2018 we're
going to see I think unions and
management working very flexibly to get
cost down I expect the government to
offer some sort of deal like it did with
Nissan but ultimately the key driver I
think is going to be what form of grexit
we have going forward
realistically then what can the
government do it's interesting you say
that there could be some sort of deal
but what can the government actually do
in practice well I think we've just seen
the government screen paper on
industrial strategy oddly that didn't
mention very much about the supply chain
so I think one of the things it could do
is to help rebuild the supply chain in
the UK so that there is more local
sourcing of components it can help as
well in terms of innovation and it can
help in terms of skills development plus
if you add in some launch aid for
example then you could see the
government making a case to keep
production in the UK as it did with
Nyssa interesting ago on this and this
and I've since said that they will
review that decision when the form of
brexit becomes clear so ultimately I
think what the industry wants to see is
the UK car industry as far as possible
inside the single market and certainly
inside the customs union most of the car
plants that are here in the UK including
that current Vauxhall plants are Elms
Newport aren't serving the UK market
they're serving a European single market
indeed I mean are there many plants in
Europe that are as dependent or in the
UK that is dependent on membership of
the customs union or somewhere Ellesmere
Port for example three-quarters of
components are imported it's one of the
most vulnerable I think to the form of
brexit even before this takeovers but I
think all of the big plants of the mass
players everything about Honda Toyota
Nissan and also Vauxhall Ellesmere Port
they are producing largely for the
single market and a hard brexit would
affect all of them in fact if we have a
hard brexit I really do think it's going
to kind of throw a spanner in the works
of the UK car industry you know if you
think about terrace of 4% on components
10% on the final product this is an
industry that's never had profitability
of 10% that's going to have a huge
impact on the industry going forward